J'avais l'habitude de m'asseoir dans mon bureau au SCC et d'
écouter des conversations téléphoniques
ici même dans la ville d'Ottawa simplement parce que
je m'ennuyais et que je n'avais rien de mieux à
faire et que tout continuait avec maman sur
le moteur en restant stable Eddie ouais mais ce
n'était pas  un semi-aride acide immédiat ou
non, Allen se plaindra que
la situation est par le reste du plus
avant alors que publiquement on nous a dit
des terroristes ennemis communistes et
pratique ce n'était pas c'était c'était tous nos
amis et partenaires commerciaux ces
agences ont le pouvoir qui  aller au-
delà même de leurs propres gouvernements respectifs
en 1943, au plus fort de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale, les États-Unis en Grande-
Bretagne ont signé un accord promettant une
coopération mutuelle dans le domaine de la
surveillance électronique ensemble, ils
ont réussi à déchiffrer le code Enigma
utilisé pour crypter les transmissions allemandes
déchiffrer les communications de l'ennemi
signifiait savoir que sa stratégie signifiait gagner
la guerre
en déchiffrant l'énigme les Alliés raccourcirent
la guerre de deux ans en 1946 le
pacte de deux pays fut renommé Royaume-Uni États-Unis et
élargi pour incorporer trois nouveaux
partenaires Canada Australie et Nouvelle-
Zélande l'identité du nouveau  l'ennemi est
évident le bloc communiste forme donc une
sainte alliance d'espionnage est scellée entre
les cinq états aujourd'hui la guerre froide est
terminée
mais cette alliance secrète existe toujours
ensemble les cinq pays dirigent un
réseau secret géant capable d'écouter
toute la planète bienvenue à la  la
plus grande opération d'espionnage au monde
bienvenue sur le réseau echelon
Duncan Campbell est un
journaliste d'investigation britannique spécialisé dans
les questions de renseignement en 1998 la
communauté européenne a chargé Campbell de rédiger
un rapport sur echelon le résultat était
des capacités d'interception mm dont
la publication a provoqué de nombreuses discussions en
1988 Campbell avait  déjà révélé l'
existence d'un réseau de
surveillance électronique ses révélations n'ont suscité que
peu d'intérêt du grand public Campbell
connaît le réseau mieux que presque
quiconque où il va
scandale suit Campbell est le
spécialiste du réseau échelon oui
le long est un nom de code donné par les
États-Unis et d'autres pays  dans l'
alliance d'écoute de certaines des
stations qui interceptent les communications
des satellites commerciaux, ils gèrent un
système de surveillance mondial totalement intégré dans lequel les stations d'
un pays collecteront des informations et
les transmettront automatiquement aux
services de renseignement américains qui le souhaitent. c'est depuis de nombreuses
années le réseau de communications électroniques
mais  leur tour était plus grand que
l'internet lui-même et même aujourd'hui il est
très très grand collectant des millions de
messages chaque heure en les analysant et en
transmettant les résultats dans le monde entier
les signaux terrestres des
satellites de télécommunication peuvent être
interceptés sur de vastes zones le
système Echelon consiste à déployer
d'immenses paraboliques  des antennes dans ces
zones afin d'intercepter illégalement
les signaux véhiculant nos
télécommunications le plus souvent d'énormes
balles de golf appelées ray domes dissimulent l'
orientation des antennes
après tout on ne dit pas à quelqu'un que l'on
espionne
la répartition géographique des cinq
nations partenaires rend possible
surveillance des télécommunications
dans le monde entier les informations recueillies sont
traitées par cinq
agences nationales de surveillance électronique
Nicky Hager est un journaliste d'investigation
néo-zélandais en 1996, il a
publié secret power une enquête de grande envergure
sur la partie néo-zélandaise du
réseau échelon il a même réussi à entrer dans
un  station d'écoute
quand j'ai été secrètement à la façon dont
Hawkeye stationné en Nouvelle-Zélande et
regarde par les fenêtres là où les
opérations se souviennent que j'ai vu la pièce
où elle se décompose en
appels téléphoniques ici et corrige là et e-mails
là et courons à travers  ces
ordinateurs puissants qui recherchent tous
les sujets qui intéressent et
en fait il n'y a personne là-bas
tout le système peut fonctionner tout seul
nous avons emmené Duncan Campbell dans un endroit à
Cornwall dans le sud-ouest de l'Angleterre près
de la lande lorsque la station de neige afin d'
expérimenter un chillon
les techniques d'interception de style
ici est qu'il semble changer que le lieu
de changement pendant la situation est maintenant
pire qu'il ne l'était avant
Javier de téléphone mph et contraction
avec le jeu de sorte qu'il n'y a pas d'ensemble d'étapes
par l'américain sur la symétrie c'est
bébé un Shalom  ce système très simple
petit scanner de batterie nous pouvons écouter
une communication à la fois tout ce que nous faisons est de
regarder avec les satellites vous pouvez
voir comment l'antenne que nous
utilisons ses antennes pointait de la même manière
vers un satellite proche à certains  de
ceux qui sont derrière moi, ce sont des données
qui étaient la fin d'un appel
qui est un fax
peut être difficile nous ne savions pas comment
aller de l'avant pays animal en disant que j'ai
une vie maintenant c'est censé être un
téléphone privé  appelez, nous ne savons pas où
elle pourrait être n'importe où dans l'
hémisphère occidental, elle pourrait être au Chili, elle
pourrait être en Pologne ou elle pourrait être dans un
navire dans l'océan et ce système
le capte parce qu'il n'y avait pas de vie privée
mieux ce que les Britanniques  et
d'autres services de renseignement américains exploitent
des signaux qui voyagent par satellite de manière
totalement non privée et qui d'autre vous
pouvez vous amuser en tant qu'amateur en faisant cela,
ils investissent des milliards de francs des centaines
de millions de livres sterling dans l'espionnage en
exploitant les insécurités des
satellites je ne peux pas  faites ça pour vous
assez pour être quelqu'un je ne peux pas me tourner le
dos nous suivons les principales
différences entre nos expériences et
échelon sont le nombre de communications
interceptées le fait que nous ne pouvons pas
cibler certaines conversations et
surtout les supercalculateurs qui
composent le  réseau et qui sont
capables de passer au crible des millions de
communications interceptées
mon nom est des États-Unis à l'Australie
au Royaume-Uni ces ordinateurs sont tous reliés
entre eux ils s'appellent des dictionnaires
on peut entrer par exemple le
numéro de téléphone ou les coordonnées bancaires d'une
personne à être  espionnés et les
ordinateurs se mettent au travail, ils fonctionnent un peu
comme un moteur de recherche Internet, mais
au lieu d'analyser les sites Web, ils analysent
nos télécommunications Mike Frost était un
agent du renseignement canadien, il a travaillé
pendant 18 ans au CST, l'
agence canadienne de surveillance électronique, en tant
qu'ancien haut gradé  officier, il est
parfaitement conscient des capacités techniques du réseau
si ces personnes privées
tenaient une conversation et utilisaient
des mots clés qui se trouvent dans le dictionnaire de l'ordinateur,
alors cet individu
deviendrait une cible oui tout ce que vous avez à faire
est de saisir l'ordinateur et vous êtes maintenant
à la retraite
chaque pays partenaire produit une liste de
thèmes ou de mots clés qui peuvent être modifiés
ou mis à jour à volonté et les ordinateurs se mettent
au travail, ils sont capables d'analyser le
contenu des e-mails et de les classer
en conséquence, c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'intelligence sémantique,
mais pour aller plus loin, ils  peut utiliser
la reconnaissance vocale, donc si un individu
a une voix distincte, il est relativement
simple aujourd'hui d'introduire un échantillon de cette
voix dans l'ordinateur et de dire à l'
ordinateur que je ne veux que des médicaments
contenant le mot prononcé par cet
individu et l'ordinateur le fera
indépendamment de  quelle méthode de
communication utilise cet individu
étant lui-même propriétaire d'un téléphone fixe ou ou
autre selon la presse américaine
ce système dont le nom de code est voice
cast a été prêté par la NSA aux
autorités colombiennes pourchassant Pablo
Escobar le célèbre trafiquant de drogue
Escobar a été abattu par la sécurité  forces
en décembre 1993
Wayne Madsen était un agent de
l'agence de sécurité nationale américaine maintenant
il travaille pour epi voir une organisation des libertés civiles
NSA est le chef
c'est de loin le plus grand qui est de loin plus grand
que toutes les autres agences de renseignement électromagnétique
réunies c'est essentiellement
le  le contrôle du réseau pour tous ces
différents systèmes comme un shell sur et et
d'autres systèmes qui capturent ces signaux
d'intérêt donc c'est le c'est le
c'est le grand-père de tous les
systèmes de renseignement électromagnétique qui composent l'
alliance UK USA la NSA a un
pouvoir phénoménal Fort Meade  son siège est
situé entre Baltimore et Washington
DC ici la NSA reçoit tous les
messages interceptés par échelon à travers
le globe et ne redistribue que ce qu'elle
choisit aux quatre autres agences
des 38 000 personnes employées par la NSA
20 000 notre base ici
la NSA recrute plus de mathématiciens
que toute autre organisation au monde,
son budget annuel de trois virgule six
milliards de dollars le rend plus grand que le
FBI et la CIA réunis
James Bamford n'est pas un
journaliste d'investigation américain qui a écrit l'
autorité du texte sur la NSA le
palais du puzzle en 1983 Bamford  a découvert l'
incroyable histoire de la NSA et a même pu
entrer à Fort Meade. La NSA a été formée en
1952 par un ordre très secret du
président Truman. C'était une opposition à
la CIA qui a été créée quelques années
plus tôt.
formé, il n'était connu de
pratiquement personne et pendant environ les
10 premières années de la NSA, l'existence même de la
NSA a été gardée secrète la NSA est ancrée
dans la culture du secret, ses employés
doivent se rendre chez les chirurgiens et les dentistes
recommandés par l'agence pour un traitement
juste au cas où  ils parlent de l'esthétique de notre père
ils sont encouragés à se marier en interne
et à avoir le moins de contacts possible avec le
monde extérieur la NSA est
également connue sous de nombreux autres noms il y
a un énorme incinérateur
un énorme destructeur de documents afin que des
millions de livres de documents chaque
année devenu pape et ils
en font des boîtes à pizza et ils vendent en fait
les boîtes à pizza alors l'année dernière, ils ont gagné
environ soixante mille dollars en vendant des
boîtes à pizza qui étaient autrefois des
documents top secrets et pourtant esterline ne
pouvait pas accéder à toutes les télécommunications
c'est seulement l'un des  de nombreuses méthodes de
surveillance électronique utilisées par les
puissances britanniques et américaines pour écouter tout cela, l'
un de mes travaux au CST consistait à se rendre dans nos
ambassades canadiennes à l'étranger et à
évaluer techniquement l'environnement pour la
collecte secrète des
émissions électroniques de cette ambassade et l'un de
mes travaux  était de mettre en place l'opération et de la
préparer
l'équipement doit être apporté généralement
sous le couvert d'une valise diplomatique et installé
dans la pièce et allumé et vous êtes en
affaires
cela peut être aussi simple qu'une très petite
antenne une très petite  récepteur et un
enregistreur installés dans un placard quelque part
et quelqu'un monte une fois tous les deux ou
trois jours et change la bande ou
change le disque, cela peut être aussi petit que
cela ou cela peut être aussi complexe que
tout le dernier étage d'une ambassade
composée  de 1415 personnes
par exemple à Paris environnement radio très très complexe
Tokyo et autre ville
très très complexe protégées par l'
immunité diplomatique les ambassades sont des
lieux idéaux pour installer des appareils d'interception
afin de capter les communications
dans un pays donné vous voyez
par ici vous voyez cette structure  en
haut, il ressemble à un
tipi indien avec un petit paratonnerre sur le
dessus je les regarde construire je les regarde le
construire et je sais exactement ce qu'il
y a dedans tout le dernier étage en dessous
où vous ne voyez aucune fenêtre ce
serait la zone  où les gens travaillent au moment
où nous parlons, la structure au bout du
bâtiment en bas est relativement
nouvelle et vous pouvez voir caché derrière la
vitre une sorte de boîte rectangulaire avec
des paratonnerres sur le dessus bien
à l'intérieur de cette boîte soit en ce moment ou
sera la maison très prochainement des antennes d'écoute
là-bas, c'est l'une des méthodes qu'ils
utilisent couramment pour dissimuler leurs
antennes, ils ont une opération massive
en cours là-bas, vous pouvez simplement dire par
la taille de cette structure qui est énorme
qui écoutent-ils tout le monde
qui est  transmettant dans cette zone
tout le monde écoute probablement vous et
moi en ce moment oh bien sûr bien sûr
qu'ils le sont c'est un événement de fête bien sûr absolument c'est le
bureau du premier ministre numéro un monsieur plus un certain nombre d'
autres ambassades étrangères dans cette zone les
antennes là-dedans auraient un
plan clair de ces structures dans ces
bâtiments les
signaux voyageant via des câbles sous-marins
peuvent également être interceptés en 1971 aux états-unis
les communications de bandes de flétan sous-marin
envoyées le long d'un câble militaire soviétique les
plongeurs avaient placé une serviette directement sur
le câble lui-même les signaux micro-ondes
qui transportent nos télécommunications
entre les villes voyagent en lignes droites
entre les antennes espacées généralement de trente
à cinquante kilomètres ces deux peuvent
être captés vers le  fin des
années 1960, les Américains ont réalisé que la majeure partie de
l'énergie de ces liaisons micro-ondes
dépassait la station cible et allait
dans l'espace et si vous pouviez placer un
satellite d'écoute dans la bonne
position dans l'espace, vous pourriez entendre toutes
ces communications entre les villes
données  le succès des
interceptions satellitaires les américains ont développé
d'autres vaisseaux spatiaux capables de cibler
à la demande nos téléphones portables téléavertisseurs
et données informatiques leurs noms de code sont
mercure trompette mercure avancé leurs
antennes se déploient comme de vastes parapluies
atteignant jusqu'à 100 mètres de diamètre
chacun coûte 1 milliard de dollars  L'Amérique
est le seul pays au monde à
posséder de telles capacités de surveillance électronique
même ses partenaires n'ont qu'un
accès partiel à
trop de pouvoir conduit souvent à l'
abus de pouvoir
les nations britanniques et américaines ne font pas exception à
cette règle
un agent Fulmer prend l'heure du conte
fil stock mon travail que l'
établissement de sécurité de la patience de 87 à
93 impliquait la transmission de messages et
la réception de données dans le
centre de communication, ils ciblent nos organisations
comme la Croix-Rouge, Greenpeace, d'autres
organisations encore des
groupes environnementaux très pacifiques, des choses qui, à l'
esprit de personne, ne sont d'aucune sorte  d'une menace,
mais hier, ils les ont ciblés, ils ont toujours
voulu se tenir au courant de ce qu'ils
faisaient, qui ils allaient voir, Amnesty
International était importante pour inclure
qui ils défendaient et ont essayé de
libérer la princesse est décédée alors qu'elle la faisait
chose contre les mines terrestres
messages constamment où elle va qui
elle voit comment ce groupe
essaie de former ce qu'ils s'attendent à
accomplir la reine l'une de ses visites
ou le pape où il prévoit de voir
qui il va voir qui va
le voir depuis  au début des années quatre-vingt, lorsque mes
sources étaient là-bas, la plupart de leurs
renseignements n'étaient pas contre des ennemis
ni même contre l'Union soviétique, c'était
contre tous les pays voisins
du Pacifique Sud, c'était contre le Japon,
ce n'était pas parce que nous étions la Nouvelle-
Zélande avait besoin d'espionner  sur le Japon,
les États-Unis nous ont demandé par la
National Security Agency de faire partie d'un
système de cinq nations espionnant toutes les
ambassades japonaises dans le monde,
alors que publiquement, on nous a dit que
les terroristes ennemis communistes et la
pratique ce n'était pas c'était c'était  tous nos
amis et partenaires commerciaux la
loi américaine interdit à leurs services secrets d'
espionner leurs propres citoyens il s'agit d'une
règle non écrite d'espionnage dans le monde en
1983 un scandale a éclaté révélant certaines
pratiques peu orthodoxes
ou comment contourner le règlement
dans un partenariat de cinq pays  il
aurait été très illégal pour le
GCHQ britannique d'écouter les
communications de deux des
ministres de Margaret Thatcher qui, selon elle,
n'étaient peut-être pas vraiment dans sa cour, alors
nous l'avons fait, nous sommes allés à Londres et nous avons fait
ce travail pour le GCHQ, nous avons
réussi  en entendant les
communications de ces deux ministres
et nous venons de transmettre ces bandes audio
au GCHQ et ce qu'ils en ont fait,
nous n'avons aucune idée que jamais le
gouvernement se soumet à cela, mais ce
genre de chose dure depuis
des années et des années et  des années et cela
continue au moment où je parle,
mais la UK USA Alliance est allée encore
plus loin, certaines entreprises seraient
les cibles du réseau Echelon.
William Jefferson Clinton jure solennellement
que j'exécuterai fidèlement la
fonction de président des États-Unis.
fonction de président des États-Unis
alors aidez-moi Dieu
en 1993 William Jefferson Clinton est devenu
président des États-Unis son
objectif principal était de relancer l'
économie américaine le communisme était mort
au début des années 90 l'Amérique devait trouver  de nouveaux
objectifs l'un des plus importants
est devenu gagner la guerre économique dans laquelle les
ennemis d'aujourd'hui sont parfois des
amis d'hier stock d'amis a travaillé
pour l'Agence canadienne de renseignement le
CSE qui était impermanent et directement
Azon avec la NSA J'ai lu un
message direct qui redéfinissait la guerre en
termes économiques  et avec cette nouvelle information, nouvelle
définition, ils ont ciblé de nouveaux ennemis
sous cette définition, tout à coup maintenant, il y
avait Airbus et des offres potentielles qu'ils étaient, ils
couraient qui ils vendaient
à quel type de prix, quelles étaient les
gammes de produits, c'était tout compris
et c'était '  t limité à Airbus, il
comprenait un marchand d'armes français et les ventes du
GATT étaient ciblées, il y avait de
nombreux messages sur le GATT Organisation mondiale du commerce de
nombreux messages sur l'
Organisation mondiale du commerce
La NSA ne fait aucun rapport officiel
à Boeing ou aux grandes entreprises américaines qu'elle
rapporte  dans la Central Intelligence
Agency qui traite les informations pour
l'ensemble du gouvernement américain où ces
informations sont commerciales, elles vont au
département du commerce où il y a une
section spéciale de la CIA qui perçoit
que les informations peuvent être utilisées pour guider une
entreprise américaine sur la meilleure façon de gagner
le contrat l'information serait tellement
filtrée que l'entreprise ne le saurait pas vraiment c'était
même de la NSA cette
émanation de la CIA est directement liée
à une agence interministérielle l'
Advocacy Center qui est également hébergé
au Département du Commerce surnommé la
guerre l'Advocacy  Center rassemble
des informations de tous les autres
départements américains ainsi que des
services secrets ces informations sont
des entreprises adoptées à la main afin de les aider
dans leur stratégie d'exportation son site Web
énonce le message
c'est le temple du capitalisme l'état est
là pour aider les entreprises à prospérer  que cette
devise particulière soit gravée dans la pierre ne fait que
montrer à quel point elle est devenue démodée,
mais bien sûr, cette version des faits
ne convient pas à tout le monde james woolsey directeur de la CIA
de 1993 à 1995 et maintenant
avocat à Washington DC explique pourquoi les
services secrets  espionner des entreprises étrangères
si nos amis d'Europe continentale
arrêtaient de soudoyer leur chemin vers
des contrats dans le tiers monde qu'ils
devraient essayer de gagner sur le fond nous
n'aurions vraiment aucune raison de recueillir
des renseignements secrets auprès de je regarde cette
déclaration avec une jaunisse ionisée  Je
souris, c'est des conneries oui ils ne
ciblaient pas juste qui soudoyait qui
je veux dire oui c'était là-dedans mais l'
impulsion principale est des technologies les potentiels de vente
ce genre de choses une
affaire en particulier montre toute l'ampleur de
l'hypocrisie du  Version américaine des
événements de 1994 Le Brésil a lancé quatre
appels d'offres pour le projet SIV a.m. dont l'objectif
était d'assurer une couverture radar complète de l'
Amazonie. Un accord stratégiquement important d'
une valeur d'un virgule quatre milliards de dollars.
de remporter le
contrat, mais en février 1995, la
presse américaine publie des articles louant le
succès de la CIA au Brésil dans la lutte contre
les tentatives de corruption de hauts fonctionnaires
par le groupe français, le réseau Echelon
leur a probablement permis d'écouter
de telles conversations
accusées d'avoir tenté de corrompre les fonctionnaires
des entreprises françaises  l'offre a été rejetée et
Raytheon a remporté le contrat jusqu'à présent tout va bien
mr.  La thèse de Woolsey tient debout mais quelques
mois plus tard la presse brésilienne affirmait
que Theon avait également été corrompu des
responsables brésiliens la roue tourne en
boucle en discréditant un
concurrent européen les services de renseignement
aident une société américaine à décrocher un nouveau
contrat d'une valeur d'un virgule quatre milliards de
dollars  aux affaires américaines et comme cerise
sur le gâteau l'entreprise en question
n'est autre que l'une de celles qui ont construit
l'échelon du réseau
Bill Clinton a raison de remercier ses
services de renseignement ils le méritent
et ce budget énorme est justifié et a
aidé à frapper un grand coup  dans un
cartel de la drogue colombien, vous avez découvert des pots-de-vin qui
auraient escroqué
des milliards de dollars à des entreprises américaines votre travail a
sauvé des vies et promu
la prospérité de l'Amérique Je suis ici aujourd'hui
avant tout pour vous remercier, vous et vos familles,
pour le travail et les sacrifices que vous avez
consentis  la sécurité des
États-Unis d'Amérique, je ne pense pas que le
Congrès fasse un bon travail de surveillance,
par exemple du côté de la maison, le
président du comité du renseignement de la Chambre
est un ancien
agent des services clandestins de la CIA, il s'appelle Porter
Goss, il est membre du Congrès de  Floride,
comment peut-on supposer que quelqu'un qui
travaillait dans ce type d'
environnement pour la CIA va
exercer une surveillance appropriée sur ce que
font les agences de renseignement,
y compris la NSA au Canada,
il n'y a pas de surveillance gouvernementale sur l'
établissement de la sécurité des communications  du
tout, c'est l'
une des choses que je
demande depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant, je crois qu'ils devraient avoir une
surveillance et une responsabilité adéquates envers notre propre
gouvernement, c'est censé être une
agence canadienne, cela ne semble pas être
en place  en fait, ce n'est pas en
place,
la seule connaissance que j'ai d'eux
répondant à qui que ce soit est simplement la NSA
et strictement la NSA, ils sont les
seuls à prendre leurs réponses, je
pense que les gens sont fondamentalement un
peu nonchalants à ce sujet  ils sont un peu
endormis ils diront que je n'ai rien
à cacher pourquoi suis-je inquiet pourquoi devrais-je
m'inquiéter à ce sujet bien avec ce genre d'
attitude cette personne peut se réveiller un
matin et découvrir qu'il est trop tard pour faire
quoi que ce soit et ce qu'ils pensaient être le
cas
je ne fais rien de mal peut un jour
être illégal mais il est alors trop tard pour faire quoi que ce soit
mais chillon est un
atout majeur en termes diplomatiques militaires et
technologiques pour les cinq
partenaires en tant que cible principale de  les
opérations du réseau l'europe a décidé
qu'il était temps d'agir
en 1998 le Parlement européen a été
sensibilisé à la question grâce à un rapport de
Steve Wright bientôt suivi par
le rapport Campbell le rapport traitait
de la question de
l'espionnage commercial tel que pratiqué par les américains
des questions sur le réseau d'interception ont été
déposées au Parlement européen
selon un proverbe américain
pour étouffer une affaire il suffit de
créer une commission d'enquête
les européens se sont appropriés ce proverbe
en juillet 2000 les eurodéputés ont voté
la création d'un
Commission temporaire chargée d'enquêter sur le
système agilent, elle n'a pas été autorisée à agir le
8 mai 2001, les membres de la Commission se
sont envolés pour Washington.
à la
dernière minute toutes ces réunions ont été
annulées le voyage a été écourté et
rendu inutile la Commission
est rentrée chez elle les mains vides
Carlos quello un eurodéputé portugais
a présidé la commission Echelon facto
mec
traitant ne peut pas disparaître le fait qu'ils ont
annulé à la toute dernière minute
des réunions  cela avait été programmé depuis
longtemps grièvement ne sert qu'à mettre
en évidence signifiait que je me méfiais
respecté différentes
enquêtes parlementaires ou poursuites judiciaires de
citoyens concernés en Allemagne France et ailleurs
n'ont aucune chance d'aller
nulle part tout le monde soulage tout le monde afin que
personne ne puisse dénoncer son voisin  J'estimerais
approximativement qu'environ 50
pays dans le monde disposent d'une forme quelconque de
renseignement par signal important dans le cadre
de leurs systèmes militaires et
de renseignement, le plus grand des
pays évidemment accusateurs plus
la Chine et la Russie, la France, l'Allemagne et
Israël, mais des systèmes d'écoute électroniques
pour les militaires  ou à des fins civiles sont
vendus à un nombre beaucoup plus grand de pays d'
Asie du Sud et d'Amérique du Sud et ainsi
de suite
L'Inde et le Pakistan utilisent chacun des
renseignements électromagnétiques dans leurs conflits et ainsi de suite en ce qui
concerne l'espionnage commercial, les pratiques des
services anglophones sont  loin d'être
unique PR mile a été chef du
renseignement français la DGSE de juin 1981 à
décembre 1982
DARPA bien sûr vôtre Rabbitohs c'était
au début de 1982 quand nous avons réalisé le
rôle important que le renseignement pouvait
jouer pour les entreprises plus profondément le colorant
a créé le département du commerce et de la
technologie  intelligence logique hé j'ai
acheté une leçon même un divorce amer
qui a été le début d'un tout nouveau
processus cqc sa concernait tout d'abord le
conseil d'administration un accord en cours d'élaboration
option entre l'entreprise et la DGSE
lui attrape un membre dont j'étais moi-même
le chef  pour l'ensemble de la première
possibilité de particule de Hong Kong,
j'ai rencontré les patrons de chaque grande
entreprise Frank pour leur demander ce dont ils
avaient besoin en termes d'informations dont nous
bénéficions à partir de ce moment-là, notre mission
était de développer un système de
collecte de renseignements qui  pourrait être utilisé sur le
modèle de la manière que les entreprises avaient
indiquée pour que tout le monde s'exclame instantanément
un dollar il parlera qui en 1982 la
société française docile était en concurrence avec
des sociétés américaines et russes pour un
contrat en Inde c'est là que la DGSE est
intervenue
I  m'a trompé sur des plâtres certains de nos
agents avaient réussi à infiltrer
certaines organisations militaires blessées
susceptibles d'être une source d'
informations utile sur cette question pas maintenant l'homme sur
le terrain a pu vous obtenir d'abord
les propositions de nos deux concurrents
le plus drôle est  que nous avons pu
communiquer les informations à daesil ou
à leur négociateur anglais vous avez terminé
juste au moment où il montait dans l'avion pour l'
inde il a pu négocier un accord
qui a sapé les deux autres et nous avons obtenu que
l'organe des entrepreneurs soit voûté  mori
la communauté du renseignement est un
microcosme qui a sa propre guilde de la presse professionnelle
duskier est rédacteur en chef de live
audience annual les espions doivent lire
je vous enverrai plus économique super
suprême ou l'espionnage commercial n'était pas qu'un
gadget pour prendre un peu d'
avance  le jeu et c'est absolument
impératif parce qu'on vit dans des sociétés
qui sont de plus en plus riches d'
où il faut plus de copain et dans lesquelles il est
absolument vital de pouvoir que si les grandes
industries exportent nos obsessions
Explorer II donc les services de renseignement
qui ont été des soldats à l'arrière  tous
les politiciens au pouvoir sont appelés
à aider les entreprises qui sont
la pierre angulaire de la prospérité d'un pays,
c'est la même histoire dans tous les
pays du monde, personne n'a de
limites dans la mesure où ils iront
utiliser l'espionnage des communications comme  un
moyen d'information renseignement et
finalement de pouvoir
Eve corps a été chef du
contre-espionnage français la DST de 1982 à
1985 il y a 14 ans il nous faut un
ressortissant européen c'est pareil car l'
équilibre du sabot nucléaire ne s'établit jamais par
le bas mais toujours du haut vers le bas
donc  nous devons avoir la capacité d'
intercepter les Américains de la même manière
qu'ils ont les perles pour intercepter nos
communications seulement alors nous prendront-ils
au sérieux discuter alors nous pourrons parler
obtenir une sorte d'accord allez vous verrez
mais tant que nous  n'ont pas une
capacité égale à la leur il ne
peut arriver qu'ils se
moquent de vous
pour mettre en place un système d'assurance européen
le prérequis est que tous les
pays soient du même côté pour que les
grandes puissances européennes soient en  une
position ambiguë La Grande-Bretagne et
l'Allemagne ont toutes deux des bases américaines sur leur
territoire et elles ne sont pas les seules il y a
un autre cercle de pays au-delà du
cercle restreint des membres britanniques des États-Unis qui
ont participé au réseau ces alliés de l'ombre
possèdent parfois de grandes
antennes paraboliques Ashlock et collaborent avec
des américains  agences
qu'ils rejoignent dans les réseaux et ils
offrent l'échange plus limité de
matériel intercepté il y a une liste d'une
dizaine de pays qui vont de la
Norvège à la Corée du Sud qui sont censés
avoir signé de tels accords nous
savons maintenant qu'il y a deux ou trois
stations danoises qui fonctionnent  s le long des fonctions de type
ceux-ci sont substantiels ils sont
clairement liés aux Américains les
services de renseignement américains pourraient
ainsi tisser leur toile partout dans le monde
pour contrer tout éventuel système européen - Ilan
heureusement l'avantage pour les États-Unis n'est pas
nécessairement de pouvoir écouter
le  monde entier mais plutôt de faire d'elle
le pays défendeur tout en
les encourageant à ne jamais tenter de développer leur
propre système autrement dit pour leur
collecte de renseignements ou savoir s'ils
seraient toujours dépendants des USA la
grange est une douzaine ou la seule ressource des
Midlands  aujourd'hui, un pouvoir qui ne
possède pas de canaux autonomes de
collecte d'informations est un aveugle qui ne convient
vraiment pas en disant que je pourrais vous donner
des informations, je pourrais vous offrir un système,
vous rendez l'autre pays terriblement
dépendant de moi et parce que plus tard, quatre-vingt-dix pour
cent du temps, vous pourriez  donnez au
pays hôte les informations dont il a
besoin, mais les 10% restants du temps,
vous serez en mesure de manipuler cet accès
aux informations importantes bien qu'ils
pourraient présenter en plus tout était en avril quel
jeune manipulateur honnête vous savez
évidemment quand ils ont entendu parler d'informations
ils ne remettent que les informations qu'ils
veulent divulguer ils fournissent des informations
qui corroborent leur analyse et
correspondent à leurs intérêts et le reste part
dans la déchiqueteuse et tire
la guerre de l'information a commencé le
contrôle de l'information à travers le monde
est le nouveau bras qui fournit le
pouvoir suprême grâce à  leur
réseau mondial de collecte de renseignements, les États-Unis
peuvent fournir aux autres pays des
bulletins réguliers concernant leur sécurité, en
particulier ces pays seraient
naturellement encouragés à travailler en
collaboration encore plus étroite avec les États-Unis, de la
même manière que la supériorité nucléaire a assuré le
leadership pendant la guerre froide.
l'information sera la clé
du pouvoir à l'ère de l'information
comme toujours le renseignement compte
rien n'est simple dans la course à l'
information stratégique des accords sont conclus et
des alliances pour les services secrets travaillent
ensemble et échangent des informations sur
certaines affaires
nous sommes à la fois alliés et adversaires moyens
de votre  nouveau DD besoin notre cas nous avions besoin
de pouvoir accéder à certains médicaments
venant des pays du Pacte de Varsovie vous avez
supplié les Vasavi ou des
groupes terroristes ce donk oriental désagréable
donc il était évident que nous avions parfois
besoin de l'aide de la NSA do Lesley
Stahl Zeleny si personnellement  Je me souviens d'
avoir demandé aux Britanniques donc je demandais toujours
aux Britanniques certaines informations
qu'ils nous donneraient sans
problème I aux 20 volontaires un
problème
11 septembre 2001
attentats suicides contre le World
Trade Center et le Pentagone plus de 3 000
personnes sont tuées
la lutte contre le terrorisme est l'un des
nombreux exemples de services de renseignement
travaillant en étroite collaboration mais
travailler en étroite collaboration ne
garantit pas le succès la collecte de renseignements
n'est pas une science précise c'est un mythe et
une erreur de penser que la NSA et ses
agences sœurs peuvent accepter de pouvoir
tout intercepter  communications
qu'ils ne peuvent pas certains ne valent pas la peine d'être collectés
certains sont trop difficiles à collecter par
rapport à l'intérêt en théorie ils
pourraient avoir une méthode pour collecter
tout ce qu'ils veulent en pratique comme
tout le monde ils ont un budget eh bien
vous ne pouvez pas écouter  tout ce que vous prenez,
les terroristes, par exemple, les terroristes
communiquent très peu par voie électronique
si l'on va pénétrer dans une
opération terroriste et savoir quand il va
commettre un acte terroriste, cela ne se fera presque
certainement qu'avec
des espions et donc je pense que pendant longtemps dans
à l'avenir, les
officiers et agents du renseignement joueront un rôle important
dans le domaine du renseignement humain
l'électronique est importante et utile pour
protéger la sécurité française et américaine
mais elle ne fera certainement pas tout le
travail de nombreuses raisons sont avancées pour
expliquer les échecs des services secrets
telles que l'augmentation constante du
volume des
télécommunications internationales, l'utilisation de chiffrements et
les transmissions par câble à fibre optique qui
confrontent les agences de surveillance électronique
à de sérieuses difficultés à
nager dans une marée instable d'
informations, elles n'ont peut-être pas toujours les
moyens à leur disposition pour exploiter toutes
les sources
les ajusteurs que ces agences doivent
subir, c'est qu'on n'entend jamais parler que de
leurs échecs jamais de leurs
succès dont les détails doivent
nécessairement rester secrets que toute
conjecture ne doit pas occulter le fait
que nous ne savons rien des
services secrets ou peut-être seulement ce qu'ils  sont
prêts à nous faire découvrir face à
leur pouvoir supposé leurs échecs
semblent être des énigmes inexplicables la
guerre de l'information en est encore à ses débuts